this is low energy Jeremy have I gotten
trash sleep yes did this movie
emotionally wreck me yes are these
compounding to be low energy me today
yes but I love talking about good movies
so here we
[Music]
go so ironclaw is written and directed
by Sha Durkin and it's a biopic about
the family of wrestling royalty the Von
Erics more specifically the tragedy that
befell this family between the early '
880s and early 90s the film stars an
almost unrecognizable Zack Efron as
Kevin von Eric and my God this dude put
in the work both emotionally and
physically to a point where I'm I'm
concerned for his health it's a lot of
bulking up man I'm not a doctor but Mike
he looks like he's going to war for the
Imperium the man is built like Warhammer
armor another Warhammer reference for
you second one this week I know you like
him is this the best performance of his
career out a doubt without a question
we've seen him take roles lately where
you can tell he's like I want to be
taken seriously as a dramatic actor and
yeah there there's a lot writing on his
shoulders this is a movie about family
more specifically the Brotherly Love
among a group of brothers but the film
seen through his eyes there's a lot of
emotional weight on his shoulders dude
absolutely crushed it now I didn't know
the story of Theon Erics it's one of
those names I've heard like when someone
like oh do you know about the Von Erics
I'm like this sounds familiar but I've
never lived in Texas and I was locked
into wrestling for a time that time
being when I found out when you're NWO
your NWO for Life locked into that
anytime it was on in the '90s so I was
going into this movie pretty fresh never
saw a trailer didn't know what it was
about safe to say in the words of the
great illan you are not prepared that
said I will brace you a bit of what this
is about this is a film about loss thing
is you don't just see the loss it's not
just a biopic telling a story it is that
but you're not just seeing the loss you
are feeling the loss the film does build
up the brotherly love to a point where
you feel every loss fractures The Souls
of the remaining Brothers I would call
it almost biblical in that sense the
phrase I'm trying to say is it just
feels that real that first loss feels
like that first tip of the Domino in
which this family just goes on a
downward emotional spiral there is
unexpected light levity in the movie in
the form of Hope and that's Lily James
when dealing with this much loss
darkness and sorrow it's easy to feel
like the walls are closing in she's such
an anchor you know I I appreciate that
about the film I love me a good
cinematic emotional wrecking the week of
Christmas as much as the next person but
I did appreciate that Zack Efron's
character Kevin von Eric has that that
feeling of Hope in the form of love all
these elements come together to feel
like a biopic that's not just hey here's
pain for the sake of pain and it did a
good job at illustrating the family
Dynamic that sets up the emotional state
of the sons as they go down this road
the ball busting father amazingly played
by hul mcney who set up a competitive
Dynamic among the brothers he's the
textbook case the father who didn't get
to fulfill his dreams didn't really get
his shot so he's trying to live his
dreams through his sons but he's talking
to his sons at The Breakfast Table and
he's like no you're my favorite then you
then you but the rankings can change I
was
like this doesn't seem healthy is the
father Fritz Von Eric responsible for
his sons who took their own lives is the
subject of much heated debate on the
internet without pointing fingers I will
say the parental tactic shown in the
movie are not conducive to happiness
however the more interesting thing is it
would have been so easy for the movie to
be like and that's why the sons hated
the father but it showed how they loved
their father and wanted to live up to
him they wanted to live up to his
expectations they wanted to they wanted
to make him proud which makes it more
sad but also more common and although
Zach Efron is the star he's the
audience's eyes he's he's our vessel
taking us through this emotional roller
coaster it's not the Zach Efron show
this is a movie where a lot of
characters a lot of actors have that
moment to shine there were a couple of
things in this movie we'll call them
nitpicks well one in particular feels
like a nitpick the other one's worth
addressing the nitpick one is that there
are wrestlers in this movie that are
recognizable to me like Ric Flair I know
who that is he was with WCW when I
watched WCW so Ric Flair in this movie
just felt like well someone doing a Ric
Flair impersonation like when he's
backstage in the locker room talking I'm
like all right that feels real that
feels like Rick Flair when he was being
Ric Flair the character in the ring the
trash talking session before the match
that's when it felt like an
impersonation and for nothing else it
shows how these wrestling personalities
are lightning in a bottle very hard to
replicate an actor being a wrestling
persona for a movie the other one is
that there's a brother that's just not
in this movie yeah after the movie I was
like okay let's look into this where's
that brother yeah a whole brother just
not in it in a movie that's all about
the brothers it's weird that he was left
out cinematically speaking I do
understand the argument as to why
whether it's the dramas going on for
long enough it would have made it longer
and that's it's a lot of pain to sit
through we don't have Martin Scorsese or
quent Teran ino's wit to blend into the
drama to lighten it up I see the
arguments there's a part of me that gets
it but there's also another part of me
that's like well if you're talking about
this family's pain that's a real person
who also experienced that but in the end
man this movie is an emotional roller
coaster to say the least it's one that I
didn't know what to expect from it
really glad I watched it but if you are
down for experiencing this emotional
story it will stick with you this is one
of those movies that surprised me cuz I
I got out of the theater and I was like
oh wow that was emotional and it wasn't
until I was laying in bed waiting to go
to sleep I started replaying it in my
mind really thinking about it that's
when the emotional weight of all of it
really started to hit me it's a story
about fathers sons and family and the
power in a family the power to both hurt
and heal this one's worth watching and
worth buying on Blu-Ray so the iron claw
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]